sin duda alguna le está pasando la
factura de cobre porque además creo que
esto muestra que a pesar de todos los
apoyos que en el papel federico
gutiérrez tenía porque tenía una bancada
enorme de apoyo de partidos como el
conservador el partido de la u y el
partido liberal que se adhirió a su
campaña y fue el último partido que
formalmente entro
a su a su coalición el descontento con
el gobierno duque se ve reflejado en
este 23% que hoy tiene federico
gutiérrez a pesar de que él intentó
mostrarse como un candidato que no era
propiamente el uribismo fue el único que
respaldó la gestión de iván duque y sin
duda creo que el electorado muestra hoy
que no quiere un gobierno continuista y
que no quiere un gobierno que tenga que
ver demasiado con el uribismo yo creo
que hoy podemos también decir que se
abre una época post uribista en colombia
por lo menos electoralmente y eso tiene
unas repercusiones serias porque
nosotros venimos teniendo como uribe
como figura central el ex presidente
uribe hace más de 20 años entonces creo
que hoy es sin duda el gran perdedor de
estas elecciones también es iván duque